ein bisschen was erzählen und zwar das
duo patrick rafter steht hier für eine
sache und zwar für kennst du das
was geht hier soll kuranyi und heute
gibt es ein ründchen job down hier auf
dem crafting server und mit dabei ist
der patrick aufgefallen abonnenten von
cani fans schlägt er mich also der will
töten
aber ich verstehe den frauen deshalb
passt das verstehe ich den ganzen
schritt hier die alte abonnenten von
carney wissen ja viel zusammen gemacht
und letzter zeit mehr so privat haben
wir uns öfter privat gewinner
historische videos immer da wir als also
ich war jetzt ein bisschen aktiv inaktiv
auf youtube ein attraktiver fall runter
auf jeden fall gemacht
die private beziehung wir sind verliebt
das klingt wie von seinem macho oder
sowas ein attacke hatte wollte ein
bisschen und zwar das duo patrick rafter
steht hier für eine sache und zwar für
kennst du hörst und erstmal wird uns
grundlegend interessieren wie viele von
euch kennen das überhaupt noch
weil das ist jetzt wirklich schon
eine weile her dass wir kennen so dass
aufnahme einfach mal so interesse aber
wie viele von euch kennen kennen das
noch ich bin erster platz oder nee ich
bin zweiter die conti mich überholen ich
bin kein upgrade ist das bin ich dann
kann auch ein stern gestanden chat
glaube ich hatte du bist platz drei was
zweiter
ja es gibt ja drei runden insgesamt ja
wir warten einfach interesse aber immer
wissen hättet ihr bock kennt ihr das
überhaupt noch an sich kurze
beschreibung
das fängt immer so an
bitte nicht immer so an
kennst du das wenn du dein handy
verlierst und an deiner hosentasche
greifst und wo ist das und denn dein
herzstillstand deines lebens kriegs
unfair und da wenn du nachts schlafen
gehen willst dann den lichtschalter
ausgemacht aber da bekommt man dinge die
man im alltag jeder kennt richtig und
manchmal ist es also ich meine manchmal
ist es einfach so dass wir einfach
komplett unterschiedliche sachen haben
wir hatten es schon öfters dass zum
beispiel hätten auch schon so richtig
komische sache mit irgendwie von mir und
ich dachte okay was ist los mit uns
alleine sind und ich könnte mal auf
youtube einfach kennst du das patrick
und gehört eingeben dann findet ihr die
videos oder auf unsere kanäle fensters
filtern
und dann könnt ihr euch das mal angucken
und dann könnte unter diesem video
bescheid geben
ob wir das nochmal sehen wollt wie wir
das gerne mal machen
diese sind zwar normal
bald ist groß und wir könnten uns hier
bescheid sagen mit einem kommentar oder
mit positiven bewertung ob wir das
obwohl das revival wollten würden wir
gerne machen ja so dass es das was ihr
euch eigentlich mitteilen wollten wir
ansonsten auch so mal wieder ein
bisschen jump daun
es ist erinnerte wasche ich produziere
das gerade ein bisschen vor es ist in
der debatte im moment auf der server
offline geht oder nicht auf jeden fall
weil der walisische spieler ja
wahrscheinlich also ja ich finde ihn
auch mehr cool ich habe den schwänen
begleitet werde schon vier fünf mal
sowas gezockt auch finde ich ein
bisschen schade sollte der offline gehen
aber ich hoffe einfach mal dass das
nicht der fall sein wird weil ich meine
simon und so haben wir auch schon mal
aufgenommen glaube ich für eine runde
man muss halt immer leute den leuten ja
so wieder erinnern ich will es jetzt
nochmal menschlich dass man das werk ist
außer man wird so sehr fasziniert
ich finde so krass ist im moment für
bedburg gibt alter ja ich hatte da schon
längst vorbei
das ist übel nicht mein fall guttenberg
muss woche tag zehn millionen bei ihnen
also bei produkten mit dem wissen geht
ein bisschen länger 45 wochen oder so
was gläubig 52 wochen hatten ja genau
sein wo mich der grad hängen geblieben
und ich bin wieder hier oben gelandet
freunde das geht gar nicht klar
gar nicht da ich habe letztens vor einer
woche wieder meine erste folge bedford
seit drei monaten hochgeladen
ich bin aber in der ersten runde habe
verkackt muss sich halt sagen also ich
hab ja auch nicht hochgeladen aber mit
zwar wieder im pvp ich habe gemerkt als
ich danach etwas sg marl nach zwei
monaten der gezockt habe wie ich von so
guten weg gekommen und ich konnte nichts
machen so also willst du erst mal meine
spieler jetzt geht es mittlerweile
wir haben ja hast du nicht gesagt hätte
bei drei monate war ehrlich alter krass
überhaupt nicht minecraft angemacht nein
heftig gar nicht wie sie das gemacht
weil ich mir dachte halt auch
authentisch finde ich also ich glaube
ich würde auch nicht anders machen wenn
ich mal keinen bock mehr hätte dann ist
wieder dieser reiz dass es an dieser
lust hat mache ich auch bei anderen
spielen weil ich nicht so der mehr der
ultra zocker bin aber ich mag es gern
mal so für ein paar stunden manchmal in
manchen tagen aber zu versinken und
sozusagen wird vw läuft ihr auch immer
wieder gefahr anzufangen
ich mache das nicht mehr anrühren alter
sehr wichtig weil es gibt gar nicht klar
dass spieler auch mit dem kreis richtig
fand das nicht kann diese sachen sich so
schnell so dass menschen die man ja
richtig schnell von allen wichtigen das
bin ich so einer bin ich halt und
engelhardt vertritt von was willst du
noch süchtig verpasste theorien 55
ich habe in der blüte bis kaliber lachen
gewann das letzte teams weg habe ich
einfach mal so gelacht rente aber ich
einfach so ein bisschen krank war nicht
so viel kraft investiert in diesem
lacher
hahaha und alles
nein ich war so weit ich hatte mein
leben pixel neuen dienst die irgendwie
schön finde ich nicht
aber ja gut leute ich glaube wir haben
unseren standpunkt klar gemacht so czech
diesmal aus das konzept findet ihr
school nicht lasst uns wissen
habt ihr bock auf dem revival und ja
damals war das ja wirklich so damals war
immer so kennst du das unser lieblings
also unser und auch dass der zuschauer
ich weiß nicht damals ist ja ein
bisschen leer haben das jetzt nicht so
gar nicht keiner gemacht und das hat
jetzt bei uns allen kann ist so krass
gut an
das haben wir erst im nachhinein von den
aufrufenden von dem positive wertung in
den kommentaren
das ist schweigen cani die leute freien
das ja egal mir gar nicht aufgefallen
wir uns einfach das gemacht weshalb bock
gemacht hat und rammbock gemacht und ihr
also wollen wir halt mal wissen ob das
leicht wieder sehen wollen
sechs aus unternehmen angekommen ist es
so krass diese runde zieht sich ich mach
das jetzt mal hier geliebt dass auch
gegner
jetzt habe ich aber auch alle zweifel
verloren das ob die das budget macht wie
seht ihr zwei weil ich hatte irgendwie
das ok
wo kann man recht den beerster ist am
scoreboard also der unterste ist erster
also ein return dessen spectator natural
und servieren gerade rasieren genau
richtig und man sieht halt die brücke
die noch übrig haben richtig genau nach
unten
okay ich bin vierter du kannst auch
schon so ein bisschen rum tricksen indem
du kurz vor schluss als wenn du siehst
doch in der einleitung fünf blöcke oder
sowas dann springst du und lässt sich
halt runter fallen dann kannst du noch
schaffen zweiter platz zu werden auch
komm schon ich bin mega schlecht das ist
so heftig die karte bei anderen karten
da kannst du alle passagen laufen und so
was genau in das ist halt echt werden
dann will dann immer noch ein bisschen
weiter und deshalb hat die schon wieder
nicht andauernd schneien schreibt 60
grad aber die du wiederholst hier ist
jedoch weniger gewinn kräftig ok ich
glaube deine tatze die runde gewonnen da
gzh prozent gewonnen auf jeden fall
kraft gut gespielt adressiert der trend
geht
oder du hast nicht die augen träger ist
auch wurscht
ok dann wie gesagt ihr wisst was zu tun
ist wenn sie gefallen hat das leichter
und check up ist jetzt natürlich
verlinkt dann sehen wir mal wieder
macht's gut und bis dahin tschüss